- So we're trying to do a meetup.
'Cause I have to be at Mall of America
so I figured I'd be like, hey,
I can meet you there real quick.
I didn't want to disrupt it in any way.
But it seems like security
is not excited about it
or something, I don't
know the details yet.
You got to
move it to the IHOP.
What do you think?
Don't slip, don't slip!
Q&A
(crowd cheers)
Yep.
First, first I just wanna thank
you guys for all coming out.
It's very flattering, I'm sure you have
plenty other things to do.
So,
alright.
(crowd laughs, crosstalk)
Shhh, shhh, shhhh.
Go ahead.
- [Male] Alright, so
- Oh, I'm sorry, wait,
let me get this photo real quick,
yeah of course.
- [Man] Thank you so much, dude,
we love you so much.
- [Gary V] These are some young-ass kids,
you know we gotta go.
(crowd laughs)
- [Man] I'm mad I didn't bring mine.
- [Female] Yeah he almost
named him after him.
(crowd exclaims, laughs)
- [Man] The middle name Vayner
She's like, let's call it after your dad
and I'm like, ah, dad, Gary,
I'm like.
- I was close, right?
I was close.
The next one?
The next one.
Is there gonna be three?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, dude, get me in there.
(crowd laughs)
Alright, thank you.
Alright, go ahead, my man.
Where'd you go?
Yes.
- [Man] Yeah, so
I'd been working in tech startups
for the past three years
as a designer.
- Okay.
- But kind of my achilles heel
is that I didn't learn code.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Man] And that's why I got laid off
from my first startup.
- But I don't think
that's an achilles heel,
that's just, you were in one specific job
where that was a need.
Like for example,
at Vayner, we are
putting more scrutiny on people that
are double bubbling,
'cause we want people deep as they can be.
- [Man] So I mean, kind
of a two sided question,
what are your thoughts on the unicorns of
designing UX and
- I think UX really fuckin' matters,
it just really matters.
It will almost matter
The number one thing I think about now
is the UX of the voice apps
because it hasn't been established.
Like, we don't know how to communicate
with Alexa and Google Home.
Somebody's gonna create the audio UX
of the next world
the same way there was
UX designers for the web,
in the same way that I
used to design my dad's
liquor store.
This IHOP needs to be UX'ed.
Right?
It can be maximized, or
it could be more spaced,
could be more dollars, it
could make more revenue,
if it was perfect.
So, UX
user experience is everything.
- [Man] Yeah, so I mean
the follow up for that is,
working for the startup
we closed our 10 million A,
we're trying to ramp up revenue
- [Gary V] Go ahead, go, go go.
- [Man] And so, for me as a UX signer,
do you think going deeper
and trying more things
outside of the office
- I think you should never dictate
your long-term life's vision,
predicated on the current
place you're working at.
That I can promise you.
- [Man] Okay, yeah, that's helpful.
- Cool, go ahead my man.
- [Man] I wanted to ask you
for the past
if you could go back in the past,
what would you change?
- Nothing.
Dude you have to understand, bro
and I got part of your question,
a lot of people ask me this.
People still,
you hear people talk but
people haven't grasped
I only talk about shit I know,
even this book Crushing It
I only wrote it, not 'cause I was in need
I never wanted to write
the follow-up to Crush It.
It's only because the last 18 months,
I've quadrupled down on the
things that I believed in,
and the result,
if I did this meet up 22 months ago,
this room would be a tenth of the size.
It just would.
The fact of the matter is that
I wouldn't change anything because
first of all, I'm too happy
so I wouldn't want to
fuck with that, right?
And second of all, I just
really believe in my thesis.
I think everybody here under 30
is rushing to do stuff
to close insecurities
and vulnerabilities and
it's making them do things
that they're gonna regret long-term.
And I just didn't!
I just,
you know what it feels
like to be 27 years old
and see your college friends
and them making jokes
that you work in your
dad's liquor store.
Like, I just was able to be in my own head
and not care about what
anybody else thought.
And that would be my
biggest piece of advice,
because I genuinely believe all of you are
in a rush for that.
I don't think you care about a BMW
or a Rolex or
spending a lot of money on a vacation,
for any other reason
because of the psychological
aspects of how that positions you
to other people.
I really believe that.
And so, I just think people
the young man, I don't know if he's here,
who's like, I'm killing it,
I want to start teaching other people.
He's so young.
Anybody could do well at Wall
Street the last six years.
Everybody.
If you've lost money on Wall Street
in the last seven years,
you should literally retire
and call it a day.
Just, leave.
'Cause it's impossible not to make money.
Right?
And so, I think people are caught.
I'm saying it over and
over, I know a lot of you
pay attention.
If you're under 32, you are completely
misreading the situation.
The college debt crisis is coming.
This economy will crash.
And everybody's behaving like
10 million raising
if you don't make money,
you're vulnerable.
And so I just think
people are misplaying it.
I'm very concerned about
the lack of patience.
People come up, they put up the five
they were like, yeah Gary I love patience.
Then I look,
they aren't deploying patience.
Way too much debating in
your 19 year old head.
You know?
Eat shit for 10 fuckin' years,
work for somebody that's smart for free,
make minimum wage,
live with seven homies in
a one bedroom apartment,
that's the best way you'll
enjoy the rest of your life.
That's the furthest thing
from people's minds.
Everybody's gonna Crush It
and start a business and fucking kill it.
Everybody's so fucking great.
99 percent of these people in this room
have no shot of building a business
that is long term successful
unless they go super long tail
and super patient.
Yo.
- [Man] My name is Prophet.
- That's already a bad start.
(crowd laughs)
- [Prophet] That's
literally my birth name.
- Respect.
Go ahead.
- [Prophet] I work at
an agency and I'm on the
side, so I
- On the account side?
- [Prophet] On the account side, exactly.
And I'd love any kind
of tips that you have
maybe on
- You can't, yeah
- [Prophet] Politics
or client relationships
- I got a lot, first and foremost,
the number one thing I tell
all my client service people
is you can only control
what you can control.
Most of my client people
are so ideological
about their clients.
100 percent of VaynerMedia's clients
don't even 50 percent of
what I want them to do.
Let me just say this very clear,
100 percent of VanynerMedia's
clients aren't even
50 percent doing behavior
I want them to do
to make their business bigger.
And I'm Gary Vee!
(crowd laughs)
You know?
You know, so
I think you need to be
historically correct,
so I think the other
mistake that people make is
the other way, which is
you pander to the client.
And you're saying the things that you know
they want to hear
you need to be historically correct.
You know, if you believe in something,
you have to die on that sword
because it feels really
bad when that plays out
but you never said anything
because you knew the client did want it.
And then they're blaming you for it,
and you're like, fuck I always knew it.
That's a way worse L
than dying on your own sword.
And just recognizing that
you can't control shit.
Today it's going great,
and now that person rotates
or leaves the company
and your new person sucks,
I don't dwell on the shit I can't control.
I wanted to eat shit for a decade
and build this Vayner
machine so that I could
buy businesses.
So I won't fire the clients,
because I have a mission
in a 50 year macro,
I eat shit every fuckin' day,
I dislike being at the
mercy of other people
but I know what I'm doing
in a four year window,
and so that's why I'm choosing.
So since I made that decision,
I hate when people are like,
I hate this shit.
I'm like, then quit!
And go fuckin' do something else!
You're in fucking control,
you're in America.
Cool.
- Gary.
- Yep.
- Follow up to that, kinda
in the same industry,
I work in consulting in a dying industry,
credit unions.
- Okay.
- Old school mindset.
- I know it.
- They do not change.
And I preach to their pain points,
I manage and I build indirect lending,
which I want to talk to
you about your auto thing.
- Okay.
- The auto 2020.
- Agent 2021?
- Agent 2021.
- Yep.
- I want to email you that.
- Okay, fine.
- I work in that industry.
I consult credit unions
to work for that industry.
- Yep.
- They won't dive in.
- Okay.
- And they're failing!
That's their bread and butter.
But they won't do it, and we watch
within the last five years
they've gone from over
40 thousand credit unions in the nation
to under 8 thousand today.
- Yeah I'm super aware.
- It keeps shrinking, so
I talk to their pain points,
I show them the numbers
and they just shut the door
and say, no, we've got it on our own.
How do you get past that ego?
I'm trying to see them.
- You don't.
You don't.
I never try to sell to
people who are unsellable.
I just don't try to convince anybody.
If I have a meeting,
at a diner with some pancakes
and meet the guy,
I tell him my piece, he says no,
I'm like, cool, Mazel tov, see ya.
Just like the film
that dude made, like I
don't care what Goren does
I don't care what any of you do.
Like, it would be much
better if you did it,
and it worked and you
email me in four years
and I'd feel really nice
and your life is better, it's good.
But at the end of the
day, I can't control you!
I can't control you.
I love this new kick
where, as you guys know,
I'm like, stop watching me, right?
So, people think it's
cool to email me and say
I've stopped watching
you, I've unsubscribed.
But then their
(crowd laughs)
No no no, let me, let
me get to the punchline.
But then I watched it
'cause I was curious.
I was pumped about that at first,
until I caught something in a stream once
which put me down a rabbit hole,
now I look at their behavior,
so literally, literally
this is how I think
people are misplaying it.
They're watching my stuff,
I'm proud about my stuff,
I think it works.
They see a piece of content
where I get on this tangent
that I'm desperate for you guys to do.
I'm so desperate for
you actually to execute,
that I get to the extreme where
once in every four months,
I'll look to the camera and be like,
stop fucking watching me!
Just do!
So, I've watched all the
people that are saying that.
So they stop watching me,
and then they go watch worse shit!
(crowd laughs)
Everyone's just like checking boxes.
Oh, Gary V told me to stop watching.
To go do, I've unsubscribed
from his YouTube.
Just a bunch of fuckin' keyboard warriors.
Everybody's real fuckin' fancy
on their Instagram photo,
and their profile,
and what you say on Twitter
but nobody's fucking doing it!
Like it's super easy for me
to look in your face and say,
eat shit for 10 years, 'cause I did it!
I lived in New Jersey,
I didn't go out in New York
City in my entire 20's!
That's just fuckin' facts!
That's hard for a 20 year old dude.
But I was on a mission.
And by the way, not all of you should
most of you should not be
on the mission that I'm on.
Which means you can go out,
and you can do things.
But everybody's talkin' shit.
Lot of fuckin' talk.
Lots of fuckin' talk.
And fuckin', I'm telling you, it's
there's a bunch of fuckin'
fakers in this room right now.
- [Man] Hi Gary.
- Yep.
- [Man] So you always talk about how
firing is more important than hiring?
- Yep.
- [Man] How do you
'cause when you put out a job request or
applications, how do you determine
who out of those applications
that you decide to hire,
I understand if they fail,
you caught them right away,
but what's some advice
for the hiring process?
- For me, I talk to people
and I go on my intuition.
- [Man] How do you play through the lies?
Because a lot of people
lie and say that they're
doing things that they're not.
- I trust my intuition.
Sometimes it's right and
sometimes it's wrong.
That's why
you're being too slow.
You're not listening to
If you're debating that
or struggling with that,
then you haven't actually
consumed the message.
Usually it's your own
ego that's stopping you.
You don't wanna make the wrong call,
you don't want somebody to trick you.
I love you guys tricking me, I don't care.
Trick me.
I'm in control.
If you're in control,
you know?
So, you're letting your
ego get in the way.
- [Man] Alright, so just
make the gut instinct.
- Make the gut instinct and then, fuckin',
(snaps fingers)
Hiring's tough.
Which is why firing is not.
Hiring, you don't know.
Firing, you know Baban sucks.
You know?
(crowd laughs)
- [Man] I was waitin' for it.
- [Man] Thank you Gary.
- Who's back there?
Let's go, go ahead, sir.
- [Man] I have the card
I gave you is for my
dark matter platform website
on one website platform.
Completely bootstrapped
from the ground up,
and we are getting
clients coming over to us
from
because it's easier to use.
It provides better stuff.
Our problem now is,
we still work side jobs.
This has been our side
thing and we're in this role
where we're debating,
do we look for investment?
Or we just go all in on
getting our sales up?
And I'm just curious,
at a startup in that phase
- All of the advices work,
if you get the right money,
that's great.
It speeds it up.
I love going slower, because
then you're in full control.
People don't understand,
when they take in money,
they've lost control.
- [Man] Right, my concern is,
we might be missing a window.
- Everybody thinks that.
What window?
WordPress and Squarespace
are way fuckin' ahead of you.
- [Man] Well, actually, we have a pretty
- I don't give a fuck.
They're way ahead of you.
(crowd laughs)
Right?
You're not closing a window,
you're finding a carve out.
- [Man] Yep.
- Do you understand?
- Everybody thinks,
everybody's sitting here with a
Literally besides, I'm
gonna help you buy the Jets,
the quickest way to get me to actually
not hear anything and turn
you into Charlie Brown,
is when you say, I've got such a big idea
I'm gonna patent it.
I'm literally literally
onto the next thing.
Like, literally, yeah yeah yeah, next!
I don't think you're
gonna lose a window, I
think you're carving out
A true window is innovating,
not in a feature set,
but innovating.
When you're feature setting, or slight
If you're a platform that
helps people have a website,
you're not losing a window,
you have a feature coming that
is giving you some carve out.
Features, as everybody has learned,
are easily replicatable if one chooses to.
So I think you're overthinking the window,
which then will help you be more patient,
will then get you to the right place.
Got it?
- Got it.
- Everybody thinks they're
sitting on something.
Nobody's sitting on something.
Nobody who decided to come to see me
is sitting on something.
It's just
You understand?
- Yep.
- I'm not sitting on something.
I'm just executing ahead.
I'm just executing so fast,
'cause I don't overthink
a lot of these things that
you guys are talking about.
Which lets me go fast.
People are slow because
they're in their heads.
So I don't think you're
sitting on a window.
I think you're sitting on a feature
and you probably have some talent.
And so, I would just keep
putting brick by brick.
What is making you not jump all in?
Usually not crazy results
in a short period of time
which means you're looking for,
you're not looking for marriages,
you're looking for hookups.
That's why you haven't figured it out.
Everybody thinks
everybody is on stuck
you know what, this is a
great two themes in a row.
Everybody's stuck on the idea of it.
Guys,
it's not the idea of it.
Ways wasn't a new innovation.
Instagram wasn't a new innovation.
Spotify wasn't a new,
guys,
it's like, it's execution.
So, usually people are bouncing
around their businesses,
'cause they think they're
gonna come up with an idea,
it's gonna launch and
fuckin' nirvana's gonna come.
You know?
It's just not.
It's fuckin' execution.
Nothing I've ever done in
my life is some new thing.
I've just done it better, harder, longer
it's just in the edges.
Elon Musk is not in this room right now.
You understand?
So you're bouncing around
'cause you're not getting
the traction that you're looking for
because you're probably
judging way too fast.
VaynerMedia sucked shit
the first two years.
Me and AJ had a long
debate about selling it for
a million dollars to Buddy Media,
29 months in.
Yeah, I mean everybody thinks like
Guys, most people are
not actual entrepreneurs.
We are as a collective universe right now
being tricked that we are.
Just keep that in mind.
My man.
- [Man] Yo Gary.
- What's up, bro?
- [Man] If you were graduating in 2018,
from college.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Man] What direction do
you think you would go?
- For me if I was graduating today,
I think the best advice
I'm giving to that person
is to work for the person
they want to be for free.
Tell me what industry you love,
let's write down the 15 people
that fuckin' dominate it
right now.
And dominate it not like
they were legends in it,
and maybe they're fallin' off,
like who are the real players,
and figure out how to fuckin'
work for them for free.
Which is hard when you have debt.
Which is hard when you wanna
prove yourself to the world.
Which is hard, you know,
but it is the move.
It is the move.
I'm really happy about
this one because I've been
on this kick for a long time.
I'm so positive I'm going
to be historically correct
about this,
I'm positive.
I think when the college debt crisis
takes down our country,
the same thing will happen to colleges
that happened to banks.
We're gonna blame the colleges,
not the kids in here
who are borrowing money
even though they have debt.
- [Man] Well my payment's
only $700 a month.
- Okay.
(crowd laughs)
- And I'm not even doing
what I went to school for.
It's a joke, you're right.
- Oh it's
by the way, it's not even bad.
The worst part is that
people are being lent money with the debt.
It's not the debt.
If you didn't have any options,
your parents aren't gonna
pay for your school,
you were of an age where
all of us, including you youngsters are
still of an age where
college is the right move.
Right?
It's not that, it's that
26 year olds right now with
$400 thousand dollars in debt
are getting lent $500 thousand dollars
to buy a BMW and an apartment.
And they have no shot of
ever making that work!
It's just gonna happen again!
We're like minutes away.
Just think about your life,
over the next seven years
very carefully financially.
Very carefully 'cause I think the extremes
have a potential to be extremely hardcore.
And you're gonna get
tricked, with fruitfulness
that's built on fuckin',
so I would work for
somebody for free, man.
Yeah, but the thematics,
you've got the thematics right.
There's real marketplaces and
there's artificial marketplaces.
Right?
You know.
It's crazy.
Go ahead.
- [Woman] I have a question.
So, my grandma
has a shoe store.
She's 80, I'm fourth generation,
I want to help run the business.
- The shoe store.
- [Woman] Yeah, it's already
mouth to mouth customer
like people come from 80 miles around
a lot of people know who it is.
I want to update it and
their website is shit, to be honest.
- Yeah, if your family
business is not doing
50 percent of its business
online direct to consumer
in 36 to 48 months,
you're gonna be in real trouble.
- [Woman] What would you
suggest, what platform?
- Shopify.
- [Woman] Shopify,
okay.
Comfort based
- Shopi-fuckin'-fy.
- [Woman] Comfort meets style.
- Shopify.
Shopify, Instagram, Facebook, go.
- [Woman] What do you
think about Pinterest?
- I like Pinterest but I think
I like Pinterest.
But I like Pinterest as like, I like it.
I fuckin' adore Instagram and Facebook.
- [Woman] I was thinking Instagram.
- [Man] Hey Gary
- Yeah the guy in the back,
with the glasses, yep.
- [Man] Would you go for
something that you like doing,
or something that makes you more money?
- Like.
- Okay.
(crowd laughs)
- Here's why, especially
as young as you are.
A lot of people liked playing
video games 20 years ago,
but they became lawyers.
They wished, I mean, great ones,
they wished they stayed
playing video games,
'cause they'd be the Tony
Hawk of Esports today.
You always have to,
as young as you are, you
have to bet 15 more years
on like, and hope that
that turns into more.
You know what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Again, I got it really good,
because
what I was doing in being an entrepreneur,
during when I was doing it,
was frowned upon.
Who's over 40 here?
Right?
So we know.
There was no entrepreneurship.
I got D's and F's.
Which meant I had no shot at
being successful in my life,
that is fundamentally how it was.
You can't
you gotta understand if you're under 25,
under 30 that's hard
for you to understand.
There was no internet.
No internet.
Let's start there.
There was no fuckin' internet!
Right?
And so,
it was fuckin' school to job or
we have not
What we have not done is understood
what the internet is yet.
That's what this book is about.
That's what coming out
of my mouth right now.
It's real early.
I think the NBA is gonna
go out of business.
And I think it's the number one sport.
It's got the best situation,
I just think the players
have all the leverage.
I just think the next generation of LeBron
and Carmelo and Durants are
gonna look at each other
and be like, fuck it!
Let's just own the teams ourselves
I'll be captain.
I'll get
let's get a billion
dollars per from a brand
to pay for the stadiums and all that shit.
We'll make a deal with
Facebook for people to watch.
It's over!
The middle's over.
My ability to compete
with your family business
and my ability to compete
with my own family business,
selling wine direct to consumer or shoes,
I could buy shoes as
comfortable as they are,
and I'm sure with that
many years of tradition,
there's such great relationships.
But money talks.
And so,
it's just over.
It's so much bigger than people think.
I'll get you both.
I'll get these two and I'll go.
What?
- [Man] Best Super Bowl ad this year,
are you going to be the number one ad?
- We produced two ads.
We have no ads that we created.
We're still,
Vayner's still at a place
where we're the second
creative team.
There's still the
television creative team.
And we're not trying to
necessarily jockey for that,
because we think
for example, is this right, Tyler?
That Comcast's Olympic thing, right?
We're getting there.
But there'll probably be two or three more
Super Bowls before it's like,
these are our spots.
You know?
My man.
- [Man] So I had a question
about the music industry.
- Yes.
- [Man] I'm a music producer,
I want to know what you think
the future revenue streams
are for musicians,
just 'cause that's being
flipped on its side.
- Yep.
- [Man] I want to just embrace it,
but I'm just trying to figure out
what's the best business plan long term
for musicians where media
is just being commoditized.
- It's supply and demand, brother.
It's not just
I don't feel bad for
musicians, the same way
I don't feel bad for a
fourth generation shoe store.
It's supply and demand,
the cat's out of the bag.
You're not gonna make the same economics.
You have to build your brand so you can
make money other ways.
Too much music.
Too many producers.
- [Man] Yeah I get that,
there's no scarcity.
So
obviously, even you think
that it's a part of culture.
- No it's the most fuckin'
important part of culture.
Music's top five, in life.
But that has nothing to do
don't get confusion of
separating what it means creatively
and what it means from
a business standpoint.
- [Man] Sure, that's where I'm lost.
- Yeah well I'll tell you,
I'm gonna find you.
Here it is, ready?
- [Man] Yeah.
- You're not gonna make
money the same way,
because streaming is only
gonna get bigger, not smaller.
Then, something else will come along.
The number one thing you should do is,
you need to fuck technology
before it fucks you.
Right?
So you need to use
Instagram and Facebook and
these platforms to build up your brand
so people want to fuck with you.
24 Hours and Metro
Boomin and Sonny Digital,
they're not struggling.
And Richie Souf is not gonna struggle
'cause he's growing in his platform.
You need to build your
fuckin' personal brand.
It's the only thing you control.
- [Man] So personal brand is the
business plan for
musicians, you're saying.
- Personal brand is the
leverage point that you can
then put
my business plan did not include a
dollar sneaker deal.
- [Man] Sure.
- My business deal
had a strategy of have the attention
and then decide what to do with it.
- [Man] Okay.
Part of the brands is what
you're saying, after that
- You're thinking about
it too technically.
Let's take a step back.
Build a fuckin' brand.
- [Man] Then doors open.
- Every one of them.
Then, people will want to pay you more to
produce their shit.
Then a brand wants to reach out to you for
you to produce something.
Got it?
- [Man] Got it.
- It's agnostic.
The only leverage we're
playing for right now
is attention.
This is share of attention.
I don't think I compete with Tony Robbins
or Elon Musk or Richard Branson.
I think I compete with fuckin'
21 Savage and fuckin' Karl-Anthony Towns.
Anybody who can have attention
is my fuckin' competition.
That book, you fuckin' driving,
you sleeping is my fucking competition.
Attention is the fucking game.
Cool, see ya.
(crowd cheers)
Meet each other, there's more shit there.
Take care.
Bye, thank you.
- [Crowd Members] Thank you, Gary.
- [Man] Advice for a
college grad that wants to
- [Gary] Do I look
- [Man] Advice for a
college grad that wants
- Bye guys, thank you so much.
- [Man] Thanks for answering my question.
- Of course, man.
I like your thought process, man.
Work for somebody for free.
I'm telling you right now.
Listen to me.
Getting closest to the sun
is where all the leverage is.
People don't understand.
These two fuckin' guys
are so much further ahead of every
his whole career is already made!
How long have you worked for me?
- [Man] Two years.
- If he wants to work
for Steven Spielberg,
it's set!
People don't get it!
Get as close to the
People are gonna pay me
$200 thousand dollars a year
to work for me in five years.
That's what's gonna happen
when people understand.
Right now, the biggest
steal of all time is to
fuckin' get Mark Cuban's coffee.
To get P Diddy's shoes cleaned.
Once you get into the vortex,
if you're smart,
I could tell you're smart.
If you suck, then people get in.
And then they get out.
But if you're good, and you
can get closest to the sun,
it's over!